Welcome to the Deep Dive. We have a truly eye-opening one for you today.
Yeah, this one is really fascinating.
It really is. I mean, imagine you're a doctor, right? And you're facing a patient
with this life-threatening, just devastating chemical dependency.
Right. Their whole system is just completely overwhelmed.
Exactly. Their brain chemistry is completely hijacked. They are crashing hard. And your
medical playbook basically tells you that the best, most scientifically proven way to treat
this intense chemical crisis is, well, it involves absolutely zero chemicals.
Yeah. It completely shatters how we naturally think about medicine.
Right. No pills, no patches, just like a behavioral punch card.
We're just so conditioned to believe that if a physical substance breaks the body,
then a different physical substance is required to fix it.
For sure. We want that neat categorical fix. You have an infection, you get an antibiotic.
Right. A headache, you take a painkiller.
Exactly. But today, we are taking you through a really fascinating set of medical exam preparation
notes from a program called Pass Ready Prep.
Specifically, the notes put together by an instructor named Keek.
Yes, Keek's Notes. And the mission for our deep dive today is to explore the surprisingly
counterintuitive ways the medical field actually treats different types of addictions.
It's a wild ride.
It really is. The core theme tying all of this together is this
rather humbling realization for modern science, not everything has a pill.
Which is frankly a terrifying prospect when you're dealing with the sheer
biological force of addiction. Oh, absolutely.
Because when medical students study these board exam notes,
they are constantly navigating these traps. Their instinct to prescribe a medication is actually,
well, it's the wrong answer. Okay, let's unpack this because Keek's Notes start right
out of the gate with the heaviest hitters. Yeah, they don't hold back.
They really don't. We are talking about severe stimulant addictions.
So cocaine, methamphetamine, prescription amphetamines.
Right, the major stimulants.
And when someone is intoxicated on these, it's this explosion of euphoria,
boundless energy, and often intense paranoia.
Yeah, it's extreme.
The notes actually point out that a patient high on meth can present in the ER looking
pretty much indistinguishable from clinical mania or severe psychosis.
They can, yeah. And while that intoxication phase is super dramatic,
the medical notes urgently flag what happens next.
The crash.
The withdrawal, exactly.
Right.
We casually use the word crash when we talk about a caffeine slump.
Right, like needing a nap at 3 p.m.
Exactly. But a stimulant crash is a profound systemic collapse.
Oh.
The brain has been so flooded with artificial dopamine that it prunes back its own dopamine
receptors to try and protect itself from the surge.
Wait, it just deletes its own receptors?
It does. It just tries to dial down the noise.
So when the drug actually leaves the system, the brain is left with no dopamine and barely
any receptors to process natural joy or energy, even if it tried.
But that underlying mechanism is exactly why the symptoms are so severe.
It's not just feeling a little tired.
No, the exhaustion isn't just being tired. It is this overwhelming lethargy.
Patients experience incredibly heavy prolonged sleep and a massive spike in appetite.
Right.
But the critical detail, the thing every single doctor is trained to watch for,
is the precipitous, dangerous drop in mood.
The depression.
Yes. This anhedonia, this complete inability to feel pleasure,
it creates a very acute suicide risk.
The drop off is literally life threatening from a psychological perspective.
That is so scary because you have a patient in this desperate precarious state.
Their neurochemistry is just in ruins.
Right.
And the instinct is, you know, give them something to stabilize the chemistry.
But the trap on the medical exams is that there is no
FDA approved medication for stimulant use disorder. None.
What's fascinating here is how the medical field has to creatively pivot when pharmacology fails.
Because you have to do something.
Exactly. If a test question offers a medication as the primary intervention for meth addiction,
it's a decoy. It's a trap.
Wow. Okay.
The first line treatment relies entirely on behavioral rewiring. They use cognitive
behavioral therapy, sure. But the intervention with the strongest clinical evidence is something
called contingency management.
Yeah. Contingency management. When I first read that,
my mind went straight to like corporate HR speak.
Right. It sounds so bureaucratic.
It really does.
Yeah.
But in practice, it's fundamentally just a structured reward system.
Basically, yeah.
The patient provides a clean drug sample and they get a tangible reward. A voucher, a gift card,
a small prize. Like if you've ever used a bunch card at a local coffee shop to get a free latte.
Buy 10, get one free.
Exactly. It's that exact same behavioral principle, but weaponized to save a life.
It's incredible.
But my initial thought was, how on earth does a $20 gift card compete with the
overwhelming neurochemical grip of methamphetamine?
I mean, it seems like bringing a water pistol to a house fire, right?
Yes.
Exactly.
But when you actually look at the brain scans, it makes perfect biological sense.
We established earlier that the stimulant basically scorched the earth of the brain's reward circuitry.
Right. The pruned receptors.
Right. So the brain is starving for any signal of accomplishment or pleasure.
Contingency management leverages the brain's remaining neuroplasticity.
Oh, I see.
By providing an immediate, highly concrete, tangible reward, you are manually stimulating
those atrophied dopaminergic pathways.
You're forcing the brain to experience a healthy, structured whim.
Precisely. You are using behavior to literally manually rebuild the hardware.
That is wild.
Over time, that consistent reinforcement trains the brain to anticipate and value a healthy stimulus
over the destructive one. It's slow, but it rebuilds the biological pathways that the drug
destroyed.
So we've seen how behavioral therapy rebuilds a burned out reward system.
But that's for drugs everyone universally agrees are dangerous, right?
Right. No one is arguing meth is safe.
Exactly. Let's look at what happens when the medical consensus clashes with cultural norms.
Because pop culture has spent the last few decades telling us that cannabis is the ultimate
chill drug.
For sure.
Wait, pop culture tells us wean is totally harmless and you can just stop whenever.
Are these notes saying society completely got it wrong?
The notes make it abundantly clear that cultural myth and biological reality are
fundamentally at odds here.
Really?
Oh, yeah. And that is exactly the trap medical students must avoid.
The current diagnostic framework recognizes cannabis use disorder as a very real condition.
With actual physical withdrawal.
Yes, with a very defined physical withdrawal syndrome.
Wow. See, I assumed it was just a psychological longing. Like if a chronic user quits cold
turkey, my assumption would have been that they just feel a little bored, maybe easily distracted.
A lot of people think that. But the underlying physiology tells a totally different story.
Okay.
Our bodies have an endocannabinoid system, which naturally produces compounds similar to
the active chemicals in marijuana. And those natural chemicals help regulate mood, appetite,
and sleep. So when you consistently flood the body with external cannabinoids from heavy marijuana
use, the body basically shuts down its natural factories to maintain balance.
Ah. So when you stop smoking cold turkey, those natural factories are still closed for business.
Exactly. They don't just turn back on overnight. And that biological deficit
creates a highly uncomfortable reality.
I can imagine.
The manual outlines clear physical withdrawal symptoms, severe irritability,
profound sleep trouble, significant changes in appetite, and this deep physical restlessness.
And how long does that last?
Usually for about a week.
Oh, man. That is a miserable week.
It really is.
If a patient comes in complaining of severe irritability and insomnia from quitting cannabis,
my instinct as a hypothetical doctor would be to prescribe a mild sedative to help them get
through those seven days.
It's a logical thought.
Right. But I'm guessing the notes warn against simply tossing a sleep aid at them.
They absolutely do. Prescribing a sedative for cannabis withdrawal is just swapping one
dependency risk for another.
You're just kicking the can down the road.
Exactly. Once again, there is no approved pill to fix this.
The first-line treatments are entirely psychosocial.
Okay. So back to therapy.
Right. Doctors are trained to lean on motivational interviewing to help patients locate their
internal drive to quit alongside CBT to manage the psychological distracts.
And our old friend, contingency management.
Yep. The punch cards work here too.
Validating that physical reality seems so important though.
If you tell a patient trying to quit, oh, it's just weed, the physical symptoms are all in your
head, they're going to feel like they're losing their mind when that insomnia hits.
Totally. Validation is a huge part of the care.
But as uncomfortable as that week of cannabis withdrawal is, it's mostly just distressing.
The medical playbook has to completely change from therapy to damage control
when we look at our next category.
Yeah. This next one is serious.
Because here, withdrawal isn't just uncomfortable. It is literally lethal.
We are moving into the territory of sedatives, hypnotics, and anxiolytics.
So anti-anxiety meds and sleeping pills.
Exactly. This primarily encompasses the benzodiazepines and barbiturates,
medications that are incredibly common.
And Keek's notes hammer this home with zero ambiguity.
You must never stop these abruptly.
Never.
The ultimate trap on a board exam is choosing a treatment plan that
discontinues a daily benzodiazepine cold turkey.
Because doing so places the patient in acute immediate danger.
These medications actually belong in the exact same lethal withdrawal family
as chronic alcohol dependence.
Wow. Here's where it gets really interesting to me in a very dark, ironic way.
Yeah.
Benzodiazepines are often prescribed specifically to calm the nervous system down.
Right. For severe anxiety or to stop panic attacks.
They're designed to be the ultimate biological chill out pill.
But if you stop taking them suddenly, it causes the ultimate nervous system panic.
Your brain literally convulses.
To understand that paradox, we have to look at a neurotransmitter called GABA.
Okay. GABA.
GABA is essentially the primary brake pedal for the human nervous system.
It slows things down and creates a sense of calm.
Got it.
Sedatives work by binding to those GABA receptors
and basically holding that brake pedal down constantly.
So the nervous system is artificially suppressed all the time.
Right. And the brain is incredibly adaptive, you know.
If the brake pedal is constantly engaged, the brain responds by hitting the excitatory
gas pedals harder just to maintain basic functioning.
Oh, wow.
It up regulates all the stimulating neurochemicals.
So if a patient suddenly flushes their pills down the toilet to try and like tough it out.
They're instantly removing the brake pedal.
Yes. But the brain's gas pedal is still floored to the metal.
The alarms all go off at once.
The nervous system essentially short circuits.
It rebounds so violently that it results in severe uncontrolled seizures.
That is terrifying.
It is. That biological panic can easily kill a patient.
It is a profound medical irony that highlights the immense responsibility
of prescribing these medications.
Because you are fundamentally altering the structural baseline of the nervous system.
Exactly.
And you can't just wish your way out of an altered baseline.
So the only medically safe path is a slow taper.
That's the only way.
Gently easing off the brake so the brain has time to slowly let off the gas.
It is this meticulous, mathematically managed weaning process.
The goal is to slowly manage the dosage down over weeks or even months.
You have to allow the nervous system to gradually relearn how to regulate its own GABA levels
without triggering that violent rebound.
Okay.
So we've looked at stimulants and cannabis where pills don't fix the problem.
We've looked at sedatives where the pills physically are the problem
and you have to slowly back away from them.
Exactly.
Now, let's pivot to an addiction you probably saw three people engaging in on your commute today.
A habit where pills are actually, finally, the medical solution.
We're talking about tobacco, nicotine dependence.
And the medical trap here, according to the exam prep,
isn't about prescribing the wrong medication.
No, it's about not prescribing at all.
Right.
The trap is treating tobacco as a lesser problem
that isn't worthy of rigorous medical intervention
or relying entirely on a concept deeply ingrained in our culture, the willpower myth.
Oh, the willpower myth is so pervasive.
My grandfather quit cold turkey, so you should be able to as well.
Or the classic, if you truly wanted to quit, you just would.
Exactly.
The moral judgment surrounding tobacco addiction is remarkably heavy,
but it completely ignores the underlying neuroscience.
So what does this all mean for the just quit cold turkey crowd?
Well, it means they are arguing against medical consensus.
Nicotine is arguably one of the most addictive substances on the planet.
Really?
Up there with the hard stuff.
Absolutely.
Its receptors in the brain are incredibly dense,
and it provides an almost instantaneous dopaminergic hit.
Wow.
The medical reality is that relying on willpower alone
is statistically the least effective way to treat it.
The notes are crystal clear.
The first line treatment is a necessary combination.
Okay.
It requires counseling, PLUS, pharmacotherapy.
The pills finally step up to the plate.
They absolutely do.
The medically proven path involves utilizing medications
like nicotine replacement therapies, biropion, or vareniclin.
And I think it's important for listeners to understand how these work,
because it isn't magic.
It's targeting chemistry, right?
Exactly.
Let's take Bepropion, for instance.
It was originally an antidepressant.
Right.
It works by increasing the ambient levels of dopamine and norepinephrine in the brain.
It essentially bridges the dopamine gap,
softening the agonizing cravings when the nicotine is withdrawn.
It raises the baseline so the crash doesn't hurt as much.
That's a great way to put it.
And what about vareniclin?
I know that one is highly effective.
Vareniclin is totally fascinating.
It acts as a partial agonist at the nicotine receptors.
Partial agonist?
What does that mean in plain English?
It means it binds to the exact same receptors that nicotine wants to bind to,
but it only partially activates them.
Okay.
It provides just a tiny drip of stimulation to keep the severe withdrawal symptoms at bay.
But more importantly, it acts as a shield.
Like a bouncer at a club.
The receptor's already occupied.
Exactly that.
If a patient on vareniclin slips up and smokes a cigarette,
the nicotine enters the bloodstream, goes to the brain,
but finds all the receptors blocked by the medication.
No way.
Yes.
The cigarette suddenly does nothing for them.
The behavioral reward is entirely neutralized.
That is incredibly validating for anyone who has ever felt weak for struggling to quit.
It really is.
You are fighting a highly evolved chemical war in your own brain,
and utilizing every tool available,
combining the psychological support of counseling
with the physiological reinforcements of medication,
it consistently outperforms willpower.
Every time.
Going to your doctor for a prescription isn't a failure, you know?
It is utilizing evidence-based medicine.
I couldn't agree more.
Now, we have covered a massive spectrum of human vice.
Uppers, downers, legal habits, illegal drugs.
Weights hit them all.
But Keek's notes save the biggest, most paradigm-shifting twist for last.
They really do.
We are moving from all these profound chemical dependencies
to an addiction with absolutely zero chemicals involved at all.
We are looking at gambling disorder.
And what is vital to understand here is where this sits in the medical manual.
That's not what you'd think.
Not at all.
It isn't classified under impulse control issues or compulsive behaviors.
It sits right in the substance-related Addictive Disorders chapter.
Right next to cocaine, heroin, and alcohol.
Exactly.
And it is the only behavior that has earned that classification.
The trap for a medical student, and honestly for the general public,
is assuming an addiction requires ingestion.
Right.
That you have to smoke, shoot, or swallow a substance to be a true addict.
If we connect this to the bigger picture.
Sorry, go ahead.
I was just going to say, if we connect this to the bigger picture,
the inclusion of gambling tells us something profound about human neurobiology.
Yes, exactly.
Gambling doesn't introduce a foreign molecule into the bloodstream,
but it turns out it doesn't have to.
Because the behavior does it for you.
Right.
The behavior itself, the anticipation, the risk, the intermittent variable reward,
it hijacks the exact same reward circuitry in the brain as a physical drug.
It's like the famous experiments with pigeons, right?
Oh, yeah, the skitter boxes.
Yeah.
If you give an animal a reward, every single time it pushes a button, it gets bored.
But if you give it a reward at random, unpredictable intervals,
it will push that button until it literally collapses.
Yeah.
The anticipation is where the dopamine spike happens, not just the payout.
When you look at the functional MRI scans of a pathological gambler watching a roulette wheel spin,
the neural pathways lighting up, and the structural changes occurring in the brain,
they are virtually identical to someone taking a hit of cocaine.
That is just mind blowing.
The brain's dopamine system just doesn't care if the spike comes from a chemical
binding to a receptor or from the flashing lights of a slot machine.
Let me try to visualize this with an analogy.
Okay, let's hear it.
If the human brain is a computer, a chemical drug like meth or alcohol
is like plugging in a corrupted toxic USB drive.
Right.
You are physically inserting a piece of bad hardware and the computer starts failing.
But gambling, gambling is a software virus.
That is a perfect way to conceptualize the distinction.
It's a malicious code downloaded over the Wi-Fi.
It crashes the exact same operating system.
It ruins the computer entirely, but it does it without physically inserting anything tangible.
And because it is a software virus, the treatment protocol has to reflect that.
Meaning no pills.
Exactly.
There is no approved medication for gambling disorder.
You cannot take a physical pill to delete a behavioral software virus.
So what's the first line treatment?
It relies entirely on psychotherapy, specifically cognitive behavioral therapy,
often paired with peer support networks like gamblers anonymous.
You have to manually untangle the cognitive distortions about luck, probability, and control.
Exactly.
You have to meticulously rewrite the code.
Wow.
Well, let's take a step back and look at the map we've just reversed with these medical notes.
It's been a lot of ground.
It has.
We started by realizing that severe stimulant addictions
literally prune back the brain's ability to feel joy.
And because there are no pills to fix it,
we have to use punch card behavioral rewards
to manually stimulate the brain into healing.
Then we explored the endocannabinoid system
to understand why the harmless habit of cannabis actually
carries a very real physically restless withdrawal.
And then we looked at the terrifying mechanics of GABA suppression with sedatives.
Showing how anti-anxiety meds can cause lethal nervous system seizures if stopped abruptly,
proving why a slow medical taper is the only safe exit strategy.
Exactly.
We shattered the willpower myth surrounding tobacco,
learning how medications like varenicline act as microscopic bouncers in the brain
to block the chemical reward of smoking.
Yes, science over willpower.
And finally, we realized that an addiction doesn't even need a chemical.
The intermittent reward of gambling can act as a software virus,
hijacking our brain's circuitry just as violently as any drug.
It's a lot to take in.
Truly understanding the how and the why behind what works and what doesn't.
It completely changes how you view habits and recovery,
whether you're looking at your own life or extending empathy to your community.
This raises an important question though,
a question that pushes us to look beyond the current pages of the medical manual.
Okay, I'm listening.
We've established that gambling is currently the only recognized behavioral addiction
because we have unequivocally proven that its intermittent rewards hijack the brain's circuitry.
Right.
Given that fact, what other modern everyday behaviors are currently flying under the radar?
Oh, wow.
Think about the devices sitting in your pockets right now.
Think about the infinite scroll of social media, the push notifications,
the endless unpredictable behavioral rewards we subject ourselves to every single day.
The likes, the comments.
Exactly. How many of our modern technologies are slowly rewriting our software,
acting on those exact same dopaminergic pathways without a single chemical in sight?
Are we all carrying a little casino in our pockets
just waiting for the medical manuals to catch up?
It's something to think about.
That is definitely a thought that's going to linger next time you reach for your phone.
Well, thank you for going on this journey with us.
Remember, being well-informed isn't just about passing a board exam.
It's the ultimate tool for navigating the complexities of the world we live in.
We will catch you on the next deep dive.
Keep questioning, everything.